dad said is a professor author YouTube
creator defender of free speech and
secular ideas known as The Godfather and
he's spreading the sad truth I think
you're gonna spread a little of it right
here thank you so much for having me
again
so I'm very excited to talk to you I say
that to all my guests cuz I'm always
excited to talk to people but I
particularly mean it today because you
joined me for the first test show all
the way back in August
people think that Sam Harris was the
first guess but technically God said was
and the first reaping guest so you now
are the firt you were the first guest
you were the first repeat guests and and
you're doing so much cool stuff in in
this space thank you this this sort of
what do we want to call ourselves now
what space are we above fighters of good
ideas I like that fighters of good ideas
all right so I want to get into the work
that you do I want to talk about your
books I want to talk about your tweets
and I want to talk about your YouTube
channel but I saw you do an interview
with Ostra Nnamani which was really
really fascinating talk about your
history so you were born in Lebanon and
I'm gonna let you take it away right so
I was born in Lebanon late 1964 so now
everybody knows my there you go lived
there for 11 years then the civil war
broke out in the mid 70s it became very
very difficult to be Jewish in Lebanon
and so we really had to leave under
imminent threat of execution in Lebanon
everybody carries an internal ID card
very much like a passport but for for
the country itself and on that ID card
is stated very clearly what your
religion is and so if you were stopped
at particular roadblocks by militia who
were not sympathetic to you being Jewish
it wasn't going to turn out well and as
you might imagine most of the militia at
that point you know you wouldn't have
cleared those roadblocks and so we
really needed to leave and so we left
Lebanon the day that we left Lebanon and
we cleared the airspace of well Lebanon
as the captain had mentioned that my
wife not my wife my mother takes out a
Star of David puts it around my neck and
says now you don't have to
who you are okay so let's let's back up
before you we get to your escape because
I before your escape there was some
pretty amazing stuff that happened so
your parents were kidnapped by PLO
terrorist later later okay so we we
emigrated to Canada and laid 75 okay
then for the next four years my parents
kept going back and forth from Montreal
to Lebanon they really couldn't
extricate themselves fully from their
previous life in Lebanon and on one of
those trips in 1980 they were kidnapped
by Fatah yeah you had a guest
Tarek Fatah but no relation no relation
no religion but Fatah is sort of now
it's considered the the moderate version
yes the moderate to Hamas yes moderate
in the Middle East is a very tentative
term sure and so they were kidnapped
they disappeared for I think it was
eight days at the time that it was
happening when my siblings weren't much
older than me we're trying to find a way
to rescue them or even know if they're
still alive I had been lied to I was
told that they had some financial
problems that's why there was so much
upheaval in the house so during those
eight days or my parents had disappeared
I didn't know that they were potentially
you know dead yeah what they were
finally rescued they were rescued
actually because my mother's best friend
at a time
her name was asan was the personal
dresser of half as an asset and so
through those connections we were able
to pinpoint which militia group had them
and I guess it was he the president of
it was no here's a present of Syria
president Syria over Syria and then
through him I think Yassir Arafat got
involved and finally they found him they
were with a group led by Abu Nidal I'm
going on my memory here from when I was
15 yeah and then they were rescued and I
think one of the things that you might
remember from the story with my
discussion with Astra when my parents
were eventually rescued my father had a
severe injury from having been beaten
with a Kalashnikov and he had a
temporary stroke of paralysis in his
face which eventually subsided and in my
mother's case I remember that one of the
things that had really
disturbed me as a 15 year old young male
was whether she had been raped and I
remember that shortly after they were
rescued and came to back to Montreal I
asked her the only time I've ever
brought up this subject and she said
that while they repeatedly threatened
her psychologically would rape that they
hadn't raped her and I don't know if
that's true or not yeah we just sort of
dropped the subject and never raised it
again yeah so I don't know that you can
know the answer to this but what were
what were they trying to get out of your
parentage of of taking expats that were
now Canadians and kidnapping yeah great
actually it's one of the seven deadly
sins of greed one of the the owner of a
building where my father had a store in
the lobby was trying to lowball my
father to sell the store and thinking
that of course as Jews they were in a
very precarious situation he had hired
these militia to try to extract from
them a confession that they were Israeli
spies and the only thing and then if
they would then execute them as Israeli
spies somehow magically he could get
that sore luckily for my parents of
course they didn't confess that because
they're not Israeli spies and that's
what kept them alive for those eight
days because there was an ulterior
motive to get them to sign those
confessions wow that's really incredible
so now I know why I jumped ahead with
the story about your parents because
what happened to you getting out of
Lebanon I thought was fascinating so you
were talking about going through the
checkpoints and being in a car yes and
you have a very foggy memory of exactly
so I remember very very well actually we
had hired PLO militia I mean you think
about the guys that you see today the
Isis guys how they look yeah well I've
that's what I grew up with yeah now
those guys were contracted to drive us
to the airport
precisely because by close to the Beirut
International Airport there were a lot
of militia checkpoints of Palestinians
and there was no way you're going to get
through that if they weren't sympathetic
to you so but of course they could take
you and they could take you to a ditch
and shoot you so you don't really know
what's going to happen so I remember
being picked up by these guys I remember
getting to the airport and then the
store
would and on the plane yeah but
everything in between I have zero
recollection that and I once asked my
parents you know what what happened and
she said that as we were going through
different neighborhoods that would have
been hostile to Palestinian militia for
example Christian groups
everybody was engaging one another very
much like a Rambo movie we were at the
bottom of the floor of the car sort of
being hidden all of that I have zero
recollection of that yeah it's so
fascinating because it shows you how
complex the entire situation with
Lebanon and the Palestinians and the
Israelis is because you had you had
Palestinian militia people being paid
off to help Jews escape Lebanon because
of their civil war I mean it really if
you if you map this whole thing people
go this makes no sense
well I offer I've actually written about
this that you know Muslims were trying
to kill us and Moslems saved us right so
you can't sort of have a blanket
statement you know all Moslems right
that's oh so you don't believe in almost
you're bad okay glad there you got that
out right there you because we don't
want you right you miss quoted so you
must feel sort of very strange when
right now you know Hezbollah is sort of
taking over Lebanon and they're fighting
in Syria and that's your home country
and it's teetering on democracy or it's
democracy I should say is teetering how
do you feel about Lebanon now and you
might have I with you I do so much I you
know my off to children so between my
wife and I we speak five languages so I
speak French English Arabic and Hebrew
she speaks English French and Armenian
well and yet our children only speak
French and English because by virtue of
living in Montreal and I really regret
the fact that we don't have the
opportunity to take our children back to
Lebanon for example one year visiting
professorship at American University of
Beirut
you know dump them in that context they
could come back fluent Arabic speaker
yeah speaker could you do it is there
because because of the political
situation or you know and let and Beirut
if you make a left turn here then
there's an Isis recruitment center
perhaps they you don't know who's the
nice guy who's the bad guy right it
won't take much for people to find out
number one that I'm Jewish number two
that I've written quite forcefully about
some of these issues
it's very easy for you to disappear in
the trunk of a car right so I certainly
wouldn't feel comfortable given the
current situation cigarettes now I've
been told I have a lot of friends that
have said look we can guarantee your
security come back and so on
can you really so so I'd rather not and
certainly not want to have young
children right so before the the Civil
War and I know you were you were 12 when
it happened so you were pretty young 11
11 do you what was it like to be Jewish
there right it was actually okay so that
that's that's a very interesting issue
because often times people say oh but
Jews were treated very nicely I mean yes
nicely in the sense that there aren't
daily decapitations within the square
hole in the center square right you
could go about your business
but everything is nice until the
decapitations happen right yeah so you
were tolerated right I mean people knew
you were Jewish they didn't necessarily
bother you every day but anti-semitism
pervades you know the fabric of every
possible element of society in those
regions yeah now that doesn't mean that
everybody is an anti-semite but you
don't you just be quiet don't don't
signal your belongingness to this group
yeah be understated yeah and then once
the Civil War happens sort of the rules
were just changed right is that worse is
that what it was basically you guys felt
that whatever side wins this thing were
finished I mean there were Jews that
were killed and it would have only been
a matter of time where somebody would
have found us and killed us yeah so it
really was under imminent threat of
execution we either get out or die yeah
so I know that a certain amount of
people will be watching this and I'll
say well wait I don't understand because
GAD is an extremely outspoken atheist
right but he's your repeated several
times that you're Jewish
right how do you reconcile that because
I've had a few people on I've had a Lear
is B who's an atheist Muslim and we
talked about how he reconciles it and
there's been a couple other people where
we the way I reconcile it for myself how
do you reconcile that so the way I would
answer that is that Judaism or to be
Jewish is a multi-faceted identity
there's a cultural element there is a
historical element there is a shared you
know context history this is the shared
history shared lineage one of which is
adherence to a set of
just doctrines and so I could choose to
ignore those doctrines and still say I
do belong to a group of people that can
be traced back in this manner through a
genealogy right and so in that sense I'm
very Jewish but in the religious element
I'm not at all Jewish yeah do you think
you don't get a certain credibility ste
cuz of that because there's a sense and
and we're going to sit down with Rallo
togashi a little bit later but you know
I've known him online for over a year I
just because he said that he had
Palestinian ancestry I just assumed he
was Muslim I didn't know until we met
two weeks ago at dinner that his family
actually was Christian that was just a
silly and sloppy thinking on my part
right but do you feel that you sort of
don't get some of the credit of being a
real middle Easterner I mean it depends
on who you're speaking I guess from the
people on the left there has been so
much time right you know once I break
down the break break down with the
flawless Arabic then those kinds of
collisions go away right but yeah it's
it's it's quite impressive for somebody
to accuse you of that
when your mother I mean everything about
us is Arabic I mean yes we happen to be
Jewish but I mean you know culturally
we're Arabic or Arab Jews so it's very
difficult for people to levy that charge
although I have an interesting personal
anecdote when I was a graduate student a
doctoral student at Cornell I became
friends with a lot of Arabic students as
would typically happen because I have
more in common with them than I might
have with the Jewish guy from Poland
right right and so at one point one of
these guys we'd gone for coffee he said
to me you know I really I really like
you get so what do you say that as
though you're so surprised as well you
know because well you know because
you're Jewish but you know but you're
not a Jew Jew right right I said no no
I'm a juju juju it does no no come on
you know what I mean you're not a Jew so
in that case what he was saying is
you're not really the archetype of what
I imagine a Jew to be you're really
Arabic yeah and so it's the opposite of
what you asked I think all of this is so
fascinating the reason I like talking
about it it's very similar to what I was
discussing with Tarek Fatah a few days
ago that identity is so malleable
actually it's so not necessarily your
religion or your history or even your
ethnicity
or where you were born or nationality
because it's all of those things and I
guess that's why I hate identity
politics so much because I realized that
most people are like you or like me that
pick and choose what to believe and that
secular values ultimately are the things
right that should move us forward as I
saya tea
speaking of identity politics and
privilege scores I should mention that
it all your heritage now I've lost some
points because I my skin is a bit
lighter that summer but I made sure to
put on a bit of weight
so that I could gain on the fat ISM
score so it all see it's a homeostatic
mechanism whereby maintain my
victimology score at a certain point
right but but the fat thing is way lower
on the list then the other thing right
I'll bring it back and then the religion
things up here depending on what
religion is such a people should be
walking around with cards and that's
ready to and be like well here's my [ __ ]
mother I I did a thing on BuzzFeed the
other day right now privilege did you
see this on but I didn't say that they
did it how privileged are you and I got
a 42 out of Andre said I wasn't
privileged at all nah sorry pretty great
I'm not through it I thought I'm gonna
die gotta tell people that I'm off the
charts on that one yeah you'd be you'd
get a negative sick I'm fantastic yeah
yeah